Hey folks, I've got a bunch of projects
in the works cooking up for later, and
I've been loving Edge of Eternity so
far, so I figured this was a lovely time
for a precon review. I put it up to a
vote, and my patrons narrowly chose the
World Shaper precon, so that's what
we're going to look at in this video.
Here's the format. I'm going to tell you
what I think this deck is trying to do.
I'm going to talk about the areas it
succeeds in, and then we can talk about
it weaknesses and a set of card swaps
that could help out with those. To start
with, let's talk about the commander.
Hearththe hole. The world seed is a
four- mana spacecraft in jund colors
with spacecraft being a new artifact
subtype that's being introduced in Edge
of Eternity. There are artifacts that
can basically be leveled up by tapping
creatures to gain some abilities similar
to crewing a vehicle. And most of them
eventually become creatures themselves
as well. This set also brings a rules
change to the commander format where any
legendary vehicle or spacecraft with a
power toughness box can be in the
command zone. And over on the podcast I
co-host, we just did a tier list of all
the vehicle commanders which will be
linked down in the description. Okay, so
that's spacecraft. But what does
Hearthhole in particular do? Nothing at
first, but once it's had two power put
into it, it gains the ability to tap,
pay one, and sacrifice a land to draw
two cards and gain an additional land
play this turn. At eight charge
counters, it becomes a 6- seven with
flying, vigilance, haste, and whenever
you sacrifice a land, each opponent
loses two life. Initial impressions,
this seems like a solid value engine
with some explosive endame utility. If
we squint a bit, we can kind of think of
its first ability as having a floor of
tapping to draw a card since we'll
probably draw and play another land from
those two cards pretty often, repaying
the one mana if it entered untapped.
This is a fine starting point, but
obviously there are a whole lot of
things that amplify the power of this.
The biggest one is things that can
utilize lands in our graveyard if we're
able to get them back out into play in
some form. This card represents a fair
amount of ramp potential in addition to
the value it provides. Another amplifier
would be landfall effects that benefit
from additional lands entering. And a
third would be payoffs for permanence
being sacrificed. If we can get some
number of these online, the two plus
ability on hearthole will pack a ton of
utility. The eight plus modality is a
bit less appealing to me to get early on
since it makes our commander more
removable without putting on much
pressure in most cases, but it's a nice
tool to have in our toolbox as something
that can be turned on right before a big
land sacrifice play. Overall, a nice
package. So, how does this deck work
with this commander? Well, there are six
cards that can recur multiple lands from
the graveyard. Three instantaneous and
three more gradual, along with a number
of other cards that can sacrifice lands
to perform effects. This to me
represents a core ramp engine of the
deck. Sacrificing lands to perform
various effects before spitting those
sacrificed lands back out into play.
Building a lot of value and mana in the
process. Men and value don't win games
though. So what are our payoffs for
futzing with lands? Three main things.
Four landfall cards, nine payoffs for
sacrificing permanence, and four cards
that check the number of lands in
graveyards. with most of these payoff
cards amplifying a player's board or
pushing damage in some way. To support
this game plan, there's a pretty wide
and diverse removal suite as well as a
deliciously high land count of 42. So,
to recap, this deck is trying to build
mana and value through the process of
sacrificing and replaying lands before
turning things up to 11 with a suite of
permanence that perform powerful effects
when parts of this cycle happen. The
endgame plan is likely going to be a
mixture of large creatures, moderate
sized creature tokens, and potentially
an explosive burst of life loss from the
commander if things line up right. So,
what do I think about this game plan?
Let's talk about what I like about this
deck. And since this is a lands deck,
I'm going to mix things up a bit and
talk about the deck's mana base first.
Overall, there's quite a lot to be
excited about here. First of all, 42
lands is a fair amount, but with a
commander that both sacrifices lands and
gives extra land plays, this number is
perfectly reasonable. In terms of raw
mana base quality, things are pretty
great here. Great symbol counts in black
and green and a fine enough symbol count
in red, given that it's a secondary
color. Like the last precon I reviewed,
we have a moderately large count of
taplands here, but given the high total
land count, I don't really see this
being an issue. More to the point of
what's cool about this manabase, there's
an impressive density of budget fetches
here, a whole 10. I'll admit that I was
a little skeptical of the two tapped
fetches and especially the three capenna
fetches here, but these start to make a
lot more sense when you remember that
the four most powerful land recursion
spells in the deck return the lands to
play tapped, which isn't a downside for
any of these five. And the upside of
these is immense. These tie into all
three of our main payoff types. Those
being lands and graveyard payoffs,
permanent sacrificing payoffs, and
landfall effects. The amount of utility
these subtly add to the deck is really
cool. Finally, let's talk about the
typed duels. We have all three of both
tango lands and bicycle lands, which can
be fetched with any card grabbing a
basic typed land. And yes, that includes
the Golgari ones as well. The commander
team at Wizards is continuing in their
quest to flesh out dual land cycles in
precons, and I'm super here for it.
These are lovely for any players who
want dual types and don't want to shell
out for one of the more expensive
options. Even just having a little
upside over a basic tap land is really
nice. Okay, so how does this deck build
off of this strong foundation of lands?
Let's talk about the core engine here.
This deck is looking to sacrifice lands,
oftentimes recur those lands, and
generally get payoffs from the act of
playing and sacrificing lands. In
practice, this mostly works out. If
there's one thing this deck can do, it's
get lands into the graveyard. Between
the commander, 10 fetches, and 13 cards
in the 99 that sacrifice lands, this
deck is very consistent at finding ways
to fill its graveyard with lands should
it want to do such a thing. For
recurring lands, there's a somewhat
lower quantity, although this is to be
expected for a payoff card. And the deck
for the most part seems high velocity
enough to find these. It tends to churn
through a lot of cards. When they are
found, the impact can be big. Even
relatively early in the game, finding
one of the deck's three mass land
recursion cards can routinely grab four
or more lands. I ran a number of play
tests with this deck out to the end of
turn five, and there were a surprising
number of them where I finished with 10
or even 12 lands in play, which can set
the deck up for some serious midame
shenanigans if it can keep finding ways
into non-land plays. How about payoffs
outside land recursion? As I mentioned
earlier, two major payoff types are
landfall and permanent sacrifice. And
these both play pretty cool roles here,
particularly the former. Landfall is a
great tool because it doesn't even
require much setup. With the next 10 ft
lands and extra landplay commander,
you're already looking at anywhere from
two to four lands entering per turn. And
that's before taking into account ramp
or land recursion. There are three
powerful finishers utilizing this effect
as well as tireless tracker as a lovely
value engine. Permanent sacrifice
payoffs exist in a somewhat similar
realm. The commander sacrifices a land
every turn and tack a single fetch land
per turn on top of that and you're
looking at two easy triggers every turn
before considering the 13 Lawnland cards
that can help with this task. A lot of
these payoffs are pretty sweet. You've
got classic junded powerhouses like
Corvold and Mayhem Devil as well as some
neat new ones printed for this precon. I
have opinions about the exact quantity
of these that I'll get to a bit later,
but the bottom line here is that I
really like the structuring of this
deck. This deck will be at its best when
it's able to perform land recursion, but
most of these landfall and sacrifice
payoff cards have a high enough floor
that they'll feel perfectly fine even if
the deck is currently operating at a
somewhat lower caliber. This to me is
ideal for a precon. You want to give
newer players the chance to pop off and
be the big bad sometimes, but you also
want their deck to chug along and make
them feel like they're getting to play,
even if they're not having some sort of
big gamer turn. And most of this deck's
payoffs accomplish that goal. Moving on
to this deck's removal suite, things
continue to look pretty solid. Five
pieces of instant speed single target
removal, five pieces of multi- removal,
and then another seven cards that
perform some sort of hybrid role, being
a removal engine or performing another
task as well. I'll highlight some
favorites here, but the key takeaway is
that this removal suite is just pretty
great, and there's only one card here I
find remotely worth cutting. This deck
is obviously a big Mayhem Devil dub, but
I also love Wind Grac's Judgment and
Pest Infestation as powerful multi-
removal options in decks that can afford
to pay a bit of mana. There's two pieces
of Graveyard Exile here, but it might
feel like a lot more in practice since
this deck is high velocity and has the
capability to loop Bjukabog to its
heart's content. We also have to talk
about Planetary Annihilation. This is a
wild new design, dealing six damage to
each creature and forcing each player to
sacrifice down to six lands. To discuss
the card's merits here, it works
satisfyingly with both commander and
this deck's sources of mass land
recursion. And outside of that, I was
nothing short of electrified to see this
sort of effect printed in a precon in
the first place. I wear the conflicting
hats of big mana player and advocate for
incomplete mana wipes such as this. And
while I don't want to derail this video
by jumping away to talk about that for 5
minutes, I did discuss my thoughts on
this card and some others from Edge of
Eternities in a segment available to
patrons and YouTube members. And there
will be a preview of that at the end of
the video. So that's what I like about
this deck a fair amount. But what do I
dislike about this precon? Only really
two things. It lacks early game utility
plays and it has too much land sacrifice
and sacrifice payoff, especially
considering that the commander is both
of these things already. So, the way
we're going to go about improving this
is that we're going to cut some of the
trickier payoffs and replace them with
other payoff cards that are more
flexible. And we're also going to add a
handful of cards for purposes of
smoothing the decks early game and
helping with setup. Unlike basically all
of my previous precon reviews, I'm not
really going to be introducing any new
elements to this deck. The ideas are
already here. We just need to commit a
bit harder to the better choices in this
deck. Let's start with cuts first. Lone
crafter fawn. Unless you just want an
outlet to discard lands, which I don't
think this deck really wants. The two
requirements to make the ETB good won't
be lining up often enough. Scouring
Swarm is honestly just a pretty mediocre
card. Obviously, flying is nice and
there's a bit of explosive potential,
but each of the conditions on the card
are too difficult to meet to justify
their respective payoffs, and it doesn't
even have two power to get Hearthhold
juiced up in one go. Worldbreaker costs
way too much mana for the utility it
provides to this deck, so it's also got
to go. Sprouting Goblin at least
accomplishes a couple tasks the deck
beguely wants, but the overall package
here is still a bit meh. Likewise, I
sort of see the vision with
groundskeeper, and I'd be okay with it
if it was a 2-1. But as things stand,
the use cases for it just aren't wide
enough. Urg Spawn of Tur sadly just
doesn't do enough for my liking, being
neither a great early game play nor a
particularly ideal later play. Finally,
this deck is just a bit overloaded on
higher cost and trickier to use payoffs.
And the two I'm choosing to cut here are
Mazerk Crawl Death Priest and Centaur
Vinecrasher. If you love these cards, I
don't know, pretend I named two other
payoff cards you like a bit less. The
specifics aren't that important for
these last two cuts. We're just trying
to rebalance the ratios a bit. Now, on
to the additions. First of all, and by
orders of magnitude most importantly,
spelunking. Land untapping effects are
very powerful in this deck and the
options out there other than spelunking
are quite pricey. Next up, I did cut
some land sacrificing payoffs and the
logical replacement to me is landfall.
Lotus Cobra and Tireless Provisioner are
both great mana engines and Valicut
Exploration is a great value engine that
doubles as a damage windcon in a big
land fiddling turn, potentially working
in tandem with the commander to one-shot
opponents from shockingly high life
totals. Next up, I want to get some
higher utility two drops in here. This
deck has a lot of late game potential,
but is a little clunky right now and
hungry for early smoothers. Deeproot
Wayfinder is a pretty sweet little guy
that can filter and ramp a bit early and
maybe even a bit later, too, if we can
keep a path clear for him. House
Ctographer is a neat card that can help
us keep a steady flow of lands to hand,
and our commander's station ability
gives us an easy way to trigger survival
once attacks are off the table. Another
card I added was Undergrowth Recon, as
this deck seems like it could use a bit
more land recursion. Honestly, I think
you could even look into adding another
one to two beyond this, but the other
ones out there tend to start around the
$3 mark. And if you're looking for the
best bang for your buck, you're going to
be best off grabbing Spelunking and some
landfall cards as your first upgrades
over a dollar. The final non-land card I
added is Hugs Grizzly Guardian. This
deck could use both another little boost
of draw and another additional landplay
enabler. So, I suppose you could add
Case of the Locked Hot House as an
alternative, but I've already given that
card plenty of attention on this
channel, and Hugs brings that lovely
Badger Energy to the table. Those are
the eight non-land swaps, but I'm also
choosing to swap two lands out. For one,
the Wastes, which I guess was here as a
basic type way to pay World Breakers
ability, maybe. Let's go with that. The
other land card is Dakmore Salvage.
Dredge is cute, but I don't think this
is actually likely to ever do a lot
outside of being a black tap land. In
their place, I bring in Twisted
Landscape, a pretty high quality triet,
as well as Kess Wolfrun, which can be a
man-ynink, and a way to give trample to
one of the deck's large but
non-trampling creatures. With that, my
10 swaps are done here. Sometimes I do
more than that, but in this case, the
deck is just looking pretty good. It
doesn't need that much extra help. The
base list is a little payoff heavy,
which I imagine most players will figure
out at some point, and giving them the
options of what cards to cut and which
directions to push harder in is a
reasonable task. The new cards for this
deck are interesting. On the one hand,
my two least favorite cards in this list
were new additions printed specifically
for this deck, which is a little odd,
but some of the other newly printed
cards are fantastic and do great things
for this deck. Evendo Brushrazer is a
fantastic value engine. Horizon Explorer
is a much welcome amulet of vigor effect
with some neat upside, and Planetary
Annihilation is a wild board wipe with a
ton of different use cases. I love the
creative design space this precon is
exploring and the strange and
landfiddling nature of the deck fits the
flavor of Edge of Eternities perfectly
to me. Thanks for watching and thanks to
Architect for supporting the channel.
Architect's category system and smooth
UI really helps me in analyzing decks
and making reviews like this one. And a
link to the final upgraded list is in
the description. I also want to thank my
patrons, some of whom are on screen now.
And if you feel like joining them and
supporting the channel, you'll get
access to a bonus video where I discuss
my thoughts on some EOE cards for about
half an hour. A preview for that video
will start right now. This requiring a
discard card discarded at random I think
strays perfectly between having a cost
that is payable by anybody but also kind
of expensive, if that makes sense.
Something I don't like about basic ward
is that for those higher ward values
when you get to two, three, I think four
on a couple cards, even more so in some
cases, the issue I have there is just
that it really kind of punishes higher
costed removal. Like in principle, if we
think about kind of what different
removal costs are intended to do in
commander, let's say, uh if you're
running a path to exile, you may pass
the exile something and then play a
three drop with it. That's just the
general utility of the card. It you it
can be weaved in. Uh but you can also
kind of just have it available a lot.
Whereas something if there's like a four
cost removal spell that also does
something else um then that's something
where that's going to be taking your
whole turn but you know you're getting
something else out of it. You're getting
a little bit more values since you're
only spending one card. So there's
trade-offs here.
With that said, I think the lowerc
costed one generally is more popular and
more uh effective in a lot of
circumstances. And I think ward only
amplifies this because if something has
ward three, you have four mana. you
literally cannot target it if you have a
three or four mana removal spell.